die horrormeldungen in vielen medien
überschlagen sich die rede ist von einem
neuen dürre sommer sahara sommer und
einem neuen hitzerekord im jahr 2009 10
das liegt unschöne erinnerungen an das
vergangene jahr das laut dem deutschen
wetterdienst dwd
das für trockenste jahr in deutschland
seit 1881 war willkommen bei pixum
science fiction
die gibt's täglich faszinierendes 1
videos abonniert den kanal nur dann
verpasst nichts es waren ja nicht nur
die massiven ernteausfälle die sich nach
schätzungen des deutschen
bauernverbandes auf eine höhe von bis zu
drei milliarden euro beliefen
die extreme trockenheit im jahr 2018
machte auch anderen wirtschaftszweigen
zu schaffen
die großen flüsse in den betroffenen
gebieten führten deutlich weniger wasser
als sonst so dass der warenverkehr nur
noch eingeschränkt oder gar nicht mehr
möglich war so der fall beispielsweise
zwischen dresden und magdeburg zu dem
sterben deutschlandweit pflanzen ab und
brände haben mehrere hundert hektar wald
zerstört unter anderem im
naturschutzgebiet lieberoser heide
schnell wurden vergleiche mit 2003 aus
einem extrem trockenen jahr mit einer
gewaltigen hitzewelle und temperaturen
bis zu rund 47 grad
eine der größten naturkatastrophen die
der kontinent je gesehen hat flüsse
waren ausgetrocknet wälder abgebrannt
und zehntausende menschen starben damals
trat vor allem ältere leute denn
klimaanlagen versagten und die
krankenhäuser waren überfüllt mit
surfern letztendlich steht fest im
vergleich dazu sind wir dem hitzesommer
2018 noch gut davon gekommen allerdings
das war der erste sommer bei dem klima
experten gesagt haben das ist konkret
eine folge des klimawandels denn das gab
es noch nie die gesamte nordhalbkugel
war überdurchschnittlich warm
beängstigend und es gibt spätfolgen und
so ist das jahr 2009 10 unter extrem
schlechten vorboten gestartet der
deutsche wetterdienst warnt ende april
2009 10 in vielen regionen deutschlands
sind 2009 10 zum start der
vegetationsperiode die bösen viel
trockener als im vieljährigen
durchschnitt zum vergleich selbst im
büro jahr 2018 lagen nach berechnungen
des deutschen wetterdienstes dwd
die boden feucht werte im april deutlich
über den aktuellen werten dieses jahres
demnach müssen wir uns
auf den nächsten sommer gefasst machen
wenn die trockene witterung auch in den
kommenden monaten weiter anhält
diese könnten prognosen zufolge sogar
noch drastischere folgen haben als die
trockenheit im jahr 2018 nicht nur
ertragseinbußen in der landwirtschaft
drohen dann auch wälder und pflanzen die
eher tiefere bodenschichten anzapfen um
am feuchtigkeit zu gelangen könnten dann
betroffen sein denn auch diese speicher
sind laut dwd deutlich weniger gut
gefüllt als im vorjahr denn das sehr
extreme niederschlagsdefizit aus 2018
konnte auch durch den niederschlag der
von dezember 2008 bis märz 2009 10
gefallen ist nicht kompensiert werden
dazu udo busch vom deutschen
wetterdienst
die startbedingungen für die vegetation
sind 2009 10 in vielen gebieten
deutschlands deutlich schlechter als im
vorjahr
mögliche ernteverluste könnten die aus
dem vergangenen jahr massiv übertreffen
befürchtet auch der agrarwissenschaftler
peter grant aus götting er hat bei
messungen festgestellt dass die böden
jahre brauchen werden um sich zu erholen
der forscher fast zusammen die situation
ist an vielen standorten sehr sehr
angespannt die niederschläge des wird
das reichen mancherorts gerade mal aus
um die obersten 20 cm die feuchtigkeit
aufzustemmen besonders betroffen ist der
sowieso schon trockene osten
deutschlands vor allem sachsen anhalt
und thüringen teilweise fehle es als
folge des extremen sommers im jahr 2018
in böden pro quadratmeter 200 bis 300
liter wasser und nicht nur in
deutschland hat dieses problem mit über
trockenen böden auch in ost- und
nordeuropa lag die bodenfeuchtigkeit im
april unter dem durchschnitt und so
könnte auch hier eine neue dürre droht
und die pflanzen leiden nicht nur unter
dem wassermangel auch der transport von
nährstoffen aus dem boden verringert
sich die nährstoffe aus dem dünger
verbleiben also im boden regnet es kommt
es zu hören die draht gehalten im
grundwasser und setzt das ist nicht
alles auch die wälder könnten hart von
einer weiteren dürre getroffen werden
denn durstige und gestresste bäume sind
anfällig für plagen wie etwa den
borkenkäfer der sich bei wärme und
trockenheit besonders wohl fühlt schon
jetzt führt die trockenheit dazu dass
die gefahr von waldbränden hoch ist und
vor allem in den östlichen regionen von
deutschland ob wir 2009 10 um einen
weiteren dürre sommer
kommen steht noch in den sternen dies
hängt einzig und allein davon ab ob die
momentane trockenheit weiter anhält doch
ob dies der fall sein wird kann keine
wetterprognose dieser welt vorhersagen
wenn es von juni bis august dagegen ohne
ende regnet werden uns keine sorgen über
die dürr machen müssen dann wohl eher
über hochwasser doch auszuschließen ist
eine anstehende trockenheit keinesfalls
denn schließlich wird genau das vom
klimawandel begünstigt und so steht
bereits jetzt fest dass die probleme mit
trockenheit und dürre in der zukunft
keineswegs kleiner werden im gegenteil
der niederschlags zyklus in mitteleuropa
verschiebt sich schon seit jahren hin
immer mehr ins extreme im winter haben
die regenmengen demnach um rund zehn
prozent zugenommen
deutlich trockener dagegen präsentieren
sich die sommermonate regionale
klimamodelle bestätigen dass und
prognostizieren für deutschland eine
höhere wahrscheinlichkeit für längere
trockenphasen der klimawandel lässt
grüßen dazu srg morus ein sprecher der
nichtregierungsorganisation european
environment büro die häufigkeit und
intensität von wirren wird aufgrund des
klimawandels zunehmend auf dasselbe
ergebnis kam auch ein forschungsteam vom
helmholtz zentrum für umweltforschung fz
im vergangenen jahr dazu heißt es auf
der webseite
die globale klimaerwärmung
wirtschaftsproblemen der dürren in
europa verschärfen wird werden länger
dauern mehr flächen und damit mehr
menschen betreffen erwärmt sich die erde
um drei grad celsius werden
extremereignisse wie die dürre im jahr
2030 künftig in weiten teilen europas
der normalzustand sein
eine der großen fragen lautet dann wie
es mit der landwirtschaft weitergehen
soll
denn für die bewässerung ihrer felder
nutzen die bauern grundwasser doch wenn
die wasserspeicher im boden nicht durch
regen aufgefüllt werden nehmen auch
diese reserven irgendwann zur neige doch
wir können im ganzen horror szenario
entgegenwirken das betonen auch die
fachleute vom usc die auswirkungen der
globalen erwärmung können teilweise mit
technischen anpassungen gemindert werden
diese sind jedoch kostspielig
gemeint ist damit die konsequente
umsetzung der klimaschutzziele des
pariser abkommens sprich ausbau des
bahnverkehrs weniger individualverkehr
kohleausstieg energieerzeugung mit
regenerativen
die elektromobilität und so weiter und
ganz wichtig denn auch wir können ganz
konkret etwas jetzt tun wir können am 26
mai zur europawahl gehen und genau die
partei wählen die die standpunkte
vertritt die jetzt wichtig sind und
unser überleben sichern wir sind
diejenigen die entscheiden also lasst es
uns tun hashtag diesmal wähle ich mehr
dazu im video von phoenix eu wahl so
funktioniert die europawahl am 26 mai
2009 10 anklicken anschauen und zur wahl
gehen würde ich mal sagen wir sehen uns
am 26 mai im wahllokal bis dann bleibt